okay hi everyone my talk is gonna be
titled plumbing and python pipelines for
data for data science applications and I
joined blue yonder a couple of months
ago and just to give you a little bit of
background about what we do so blue
yonder is a data science company and we
develop predictive applications in
particular for retail so for instance a
large supermarket change chains and
there we do things like replenishment
optimizations so that just means we try
to predict the demand for certain
articles and then give suggest
suggestions to the supermarket regarding
the stock so how much they should buy or
we do things like price optimization
where we try to estimate based on
historical data the relationship between
sales and prices and based on that try
to set optimal prices and just to give
you an idea so currently we do more than
500 billion automated decisions per
month for our customers so we're dealing
with a lot of data in this context so
you're a couple of examples what we
typically do so we do machine learning
we do things like data analysis we do
reporting for customers and when we look
at these examples they often look quite
similar in the sense that we have a
couple of functions and they get applied
one after the other
so basically we have pipelines so we
have the series of processing steps and
the output of one function is fare to
the next function so in this simple
example we might get some data at first
do some computation maybe some machine
learning maybe create a plot and that
create a report for instance for a
customer so what this talk is going to
be about is recognizing this fact that a
lot of our software has the structure of
basically being pipelines we created the
data flow library at blue yonder
and which basically facilitates the
process of creating pipelines so I'm
going to talk about that but I'm not
only going to talk about that library
but also the principles behind it and
how it affected our development which is
perhaps even more important so the talks
government gonna be structured into
three parts first I'm going to talk a
little bit about pipelines what you can
do with them how you write them then I'm
going to go into a little bit of detail
about the implementation and technical
details of the library and in the third
part I'm going to talk about the effects
this had on our development process so
part one pipelines so here's the same
example that you saw before where we got
some data at first do some computation
create a plot and then create some
report in plain Python code that works
fine and again
realizing that this is basically how a
lot of our code looks like it would be
nice to make the somehow more explicit
you can obviously do it this way but it
would be nice to actually yeah abstract
away and what we what we really want to
do here and we also want to encourage
developers to write code as pipelines
and this is the main motivation for
creating this library which we call
llamar so again here's the same example
at the top we have these four function
calls that's fine and below that you see
how we would write this as a pipeline so
it's basically just a list with a couple
of functions in this list so nothing
fancy there and if we now take this list
this pipeline we can obviously execute
it it's pretty simple just execute the
first function take the output feed it
to the next function and so on until you
get your result and this is basically
what the library does so we have this
function called run pipeline and we put
our pipeline into that function and that
just means it
executed and then we get this flow that
you see at the bottom we get the day
that do the computation create the plot
create the report quite simple so you
might ask yourself what is the advantage
of writing pipelines in this way because
we can obviously do it and play in
Python code that I showed you before so
one of the nice things is that we have a
clear separation of the Declaration and
the execution of the pipeline here and
that means that the actual code does not
really depend on the backend so we can't
switch back ends really easily this
implementation of this run pipeline
function can be whatever you want it to
be and I'm going to talk about that
later on how we can switch these
different backends it also encourages a
functional style of programming whether
you're a fan of that or not but there
are obvious advantages to that
so for instance testability another nice
thing in this representation is that
pipelines are just Python lists so we
can do all these standard operations on
list so we can do slicing concatenation
whatever you want a nice side effect
which we didn't even really intend when
we developed this library in the first
place is that it's really easy than to
do parallelization because only the
backend has to take care of that and all
these functions that you see at the top
they don't really have to know anything
about that so how do you define
pipelines in llamar I already showed you
an example here's another example
slightly more complex a typical use case
so oftentimes we have functions which
might take several per parameters
several arguments and in Yamal we expect
a function always to take one argument
so what you might want to do is use this
partial construct and bind a certain
value to a parameter which you then see
you there at the bottom we set some
parameter on this compute function in
this case so again we don't need
anything special from a library here
this is just standard
Python code so it gets a little more
interesting once we do something like
splitting up data so we have this
concept called a splitter in Yama which
basically means we have a generator in
Python so you see this function get
chunks and this gets us several chunks
of data it yields them and we also have
to tell your mouth that this is in fact
a splitter so you see in this pipeline
definition we annotate the function with
this splitter so Yamaha knows that this
yeah there's something special in the
pipeline and what you end up with is
this thing at the bottom now these
things these different chunks basically
can get processed in parallel but the
same functions get applied to each chunk
we cannot only split data we can also
reduce it so that makes it possible to
write something like split MapReduce so
in this case we might not want to create
a report for each for each chunk but
instead might want to create a single
report where we join these different
data paths again and this is done with
what is called an yamout a reducer so a
reducer in this case is just a function
which you see there at the top this
create report function which jason
basically just expects a list of the
outputs of the functions that were
running before and we also have to
annotate it again so we have this
reducer oh I shouldn't do that I guess
where is it gone
it's gone
nevermind sorry about that
so yeah as I was saying we have to
annotate this function again tell your
mouth that this is reducer and this in
this case and that means it knows that
it has to take these different paths and
join it there another useful thing which
we can do with this kind of thing is we
can fork data paths so at some point in
the pipeline we might want to take a
piece of data and push it to different
functions so we take the same data in
both paths here and we use this fork and
then we can push the same data to this
function create plot which we had before
and then another function called create
floor too so we'll get another plot and
yeah
all these again are joined in the end
and we create a single report so you see
there in the pipeline definition in the
third line of the definition we have
this for construct which basically means
take the data that we have there and
push it to these different functions
which we which we have there if we have
these reducers another essential thing
you need is something like scopes
because before we have this single
reducer and it just took all the data
and put it into a single report that's
not what you always want to do so in
this case you might want to create a
separate report for each chunk and you
want to tell exactly how much this
particular reducer should join and that
means we have to put it into a scope so
this fork statement and the reducer get
this scope and that tells your mouth to
only join these two data paths for each
chunk
that basically means we can nest
pipelines very easily okay so another
very useful construct in Yama are labels
and the control flow we can define in
terms of these labels so what we can do
is we can assign labels to data so there
we have this function labeled data and
we not we do not just yield the data
itself in this case but also a label so
we get this tuple and we also tell you
amount in this case that this is a
special thing that this is a label by
putting this returns label around the
whole thing so if you if you look at
this thing at the bottom and Yama now
knows that the first chunk is called a
and the second chunk is called B and
what you now can do is something like a
switch case where we can match based on
the labels and then execute different
functions because in this case chunk a
perhaps should be processed by function
compute but Shang B should be processed
by a different function called compute 2
in this case and this is what you can do
if you look at this case statement we
have two called when because we couldn't
you ill use if we match based on the
labels and then we execute whatever we
have there in this pipeline statement so
this is quite useful in practice
actually and it is very useful because
the functions themselves do not need do
not need to be aware of this so
obviously we could have a computer
containing some if statement and then do
the control flow there but what we want
to do is take existing functions that
are may be part of some library that
know nothing about this control flow and
we still want to be able to plug them
into pipelines without writing some
wrapper function around it so we can do
the entire control flow at the pipeline
level here another important thing is
that which function is called with
which piece of data is actually
determined dynamically so we cannot
before executing the pipeline we do not
know the entire execution graph but this
is basically done dynamically in the
splitter which determines what data gets
what label so the typical pipeline
function just looks like this you have a
single argument and you do some
computation and you get some output
unless it's the first element in the
pipeline we always expect a single
argument the first function is also
allowed to not take any arguments and
typically these functions are pure so
there are no side effects which is
obviously good for things like
testability and there is no dependency
on yamaja so the entire dependency on
your mal is at the Declaration of the
pipeline so these functions themselves
know nothing about about the library
here so what did we gain by this
well we gained a very high degree of
reusability of these functions because
these functions are very general and
this is not necessarily enforced by Yama
but it's the result of writing in this
writing code in this pipeline style so
it's rather induced by this by these
design conventions and as I mentioned
before we can have different execution
backends which is very nice which I'm
going to talk about a little bit and
what is also nice is that all the
building blocks so the functions and the
control flow are directly visible at the
level where you declare your pipeline so
a person looking at this declaration of
the pipeline immediately can see what is
going on and what is involved there it's
actually quite easy to read these
pipeline declaration declarations okay
so part two I'm going to talk a little
bit about the technical details of the
implementation so how does llamar work
internally well as I said before
pipelines are just lists of of Python
functions what we do is we pickle the
factions and also all the data we do
this using dill because it's more
powerful than them see pickle and we
schedule job using a single or in this
case rather troll use because we're
still using Python 2.7 but this is
basically what happens so all the things
get C relized and yeah we have this I
think IO mechanism for scheduling jobs
a very nice tool which we have in Yama
our pipeline observers so these are just
objects that monitor the execution of a
pipeline and get informed whenever
something happens in the pipeline which
is very useful for things like debugging
or or doing performance optimizations so
you define your pipeline observer there
this object and then you pass it just to
a list of observers which get passed to
this run pipeline function and then each
observer gets informed whenever a
function is called for instance so one
of the observers you already saw is this
graph observer so all these images that
I showed you before these visualizations
of the pipeline this is basically
happening automatically if you use this
graph observer it just yeah basically
generates a graph a graph with dot file
and you can render that and then you
have a nice visual representation of the
pipeline another very useful thing is
what we call a performance observer
which basically just gathers timing
information which is very useful for
investigating which functions take how
much time and where you can do
optimizations so in this case we have a
splitter where we have eight chunks of
data and for each chunk we have this
compute function which in this case
sleeps
one second and what you see here at the
bottom is this dark blue road that's
just the execution time of the entire
pipeline so little more than four
seconds then you have this red thing in
the beginning which is happening on work
at zero so in this case we're using two
workers which you can see there with
this run pipeline we use this executor
which tells which tells us that we're
using here to work us in this case and
after this splitter and we have four
different computations and they're
nicely scheduled on the two workers so
this brings me to the different
execution backends so currently in Yama
we have three execution backends we have
one very simple for local sequential
execution we have one for parallel
execution using sub processes and we
have one for remote parallel execution
where we use an internally developed
cluster back-end so these are the three
we have currently however it's actually
quite easy to write these different
backends so anything that can schedule
jobs asynchronously could be used here
so things like spark or distributed are
things we have thought about and it
should actually be possible and not that
difficult to write backends for llamar
based on these frameworks so here's an
example of the sequential executed
exactly what you would expect so you
have a single work and all the functions
get scheduled one after the other here's
another example again using the SAP
process executors so we're still on a
single machine here where we use three
workers and again you can see how these
jobs get distributed to the different
workers I don't have an image for it but
we can do the same thing on a cluster
basically here by just specifying a
different execute
in this case so another thing we do in
Yama are performance optimizations where
whenever we have a linear pipeline
segment segments so at the top you can
see there we have first is called
compute and then we have create plot and
this is entirely linear so we can just
merge them to basically have a single
function which gets executed on a single
worker and this is exactly what happens
in Yama we fuse these linear segments
which in this case that I showed you
before is also the reason why you see
don't see any overhead here so there's
no idling time because nothing needs to
get serialized because all of these
functions can get executed one after the
other as basically a single function so
another thing is where we do another
kind of optimization and when we have a
lot of different shanks we have the
ability to group them by specifying a
block size where we have a splitter so
in this case we have these six different
chunks and we can block them so we have
three chunks in a block and then these
get get passed to a worker which Masek
basically means we can reduce the
overhead resulting from the scheduling
another nice thing which might not sound
like much but it's quite useful in
practice we have a couple of debugging
help us so we have the ability to
automatically enter a debugger when an
exception is encountered and we also
have an iPod on am bet that's aware of
multi-processing so if you have a
subprocess executor that runs in
different processes and you run into an
embed there it actually acts as a
synchronization point so that means you
can just step through the different
processes one after the other and not
jump into these embeds all of this all
at the same time which obviously
wouldn't work
so this brings me to the last part what
kind of effects did introducing this
library have on our development process
so and this is how a typical project
structure currently looks like so at the
bottom we have our usual Python
functions whatever they might use numpy
matplotlib whatever then at this
intermediate level we have llamar
pipelines and then at the top level we
use currently air flow to schedule tasks
but the important thing is that in
between we have this have these
pipelines which basically contains yeah
most of the logic so when we use
pipelines and projects one of the
motivations for that was actually that
projects tend to be rather different
because customers have different needs
specific wishes so it's not really
possible to write a monolithic
application because you would have so
many configuration options that wouldn't
really work well so what we decided to
do is we have these rather general
functions in a core library and and
within each project we then write our
pipelines where we can dynamically pluck
these different things together in
particular stuff like IO and the
specific control flow that typically is
yeah it's done it on the project level
and not so much on a general library
level again these pipelines provide a
very nice view on what is actually going
on so if a project manager looks at a
pipeline you can usually tell quite
quickly what is going on there and
another point is that we're not limited
to numerical problems here so your model
is completely data agnostic we can pass
around numpy errors forever but it can
also be plots can be arbitrary Python
structures so it would be for instance
possible
to combine this with tools like dusk
which is more geared towards numerical
computations you might use that within a
specific function but in general at the
pipeline level you do not have this
restriction regarding the data structure
so how did all of this affect our
development so we basically have a very
strong incentive for more for a more
functional style of programming and that
is because developers basically get
certain nice things for free so they get
concurrency basically for free and they
also get these other nice tools like
these pipeline observers for free which
is actually a rather strong incentive
for for using of this library overall we
have a much cleaner architecture
actually because writing code in this
pipeline way actually discourages you
from writing weird spaghetti code and
depending on global state so overall the
code looks much cleaner also the data
dependencies become very explicit in
this pipeline definition you can
immediately see at a certain point what
this function should get because you can
see all the functions that ran before it
so overall it's it's quite easy to
understand looking at these pipeline
definitions another thing is I already
said that we have better reusability and
we also have better testability so
regarding testability and we basically
can distinguish between these three
levels so obviously we have unit tests
for individual functions if there are
pure functions that works very well to
test them and then what we oftentimes do
is define this kind of pure func
a pure pipeline which only contains pure
functions and then have another level
where we have the full pipeline which
then actually contains the I also
getting the data from some database or
writing out some report for instance so
what's good about that is
that we can quite easily test one and
two and that already covers a lot so
this third kind of test where we have to
test IO can actually be reduced to
minimum okay so to summarize what did we
achieve by introducing this library so
we have this clear separation of the
declaration and the execution and as a
result we can easily use different
backends for the execution we have a
more functional style of programming
with all of the advantages that come
with that the functions themselves do
not depend on llamar
so overall the dependency on your mal is
quite yeah quite narrow because it's
only happening where you declare your
pipeline which is usually not a lot of
code so that's maybe like 10 or 20 lines
of codes usually as I said before it's
completed data agnostic so we're not
limited to numerical problems here and
other scheduling libraries could just as
well be used as a back-end okay to give
you a brief outlook what we're currently
working on where we actually have a
first prototype working is sampling like
explicitly annotating IO IO operations
in the pipeline so that means we would
make side-effects explicit at the
pipeline level which is also nice just
basically for having an additional
documentation where you can immediately
see what functions might be doing there
whether they are safe or whether they
might have weird side effects tools for
debugging distributed systems that's
another issue so it would be very nice
if you for instance have a failing
function on a remote system to be able
to basically re execute the same
function with the same data locally and
then can determine what is going wrong
there
and another thing finally is
optimizations
which you can do at the pipeline level
so for instance we could do caching in
particular if we have things like
explicit i/o annotations that would make
things like caching lot easier okay
thank you very much okay so it's not
currently open source but let me add two
things to that so we're probably going
to open source it we haven't done it yet
and the other thing is it's not really
so much about the implementation here
which is obviously useful but it's
really not that complex the
implementation what is really useful
what I try to convey is the concepts
behind it so writing in this declarative
style separating the Declaration of the
execution this is something where we
found out that this is extremely useful
so one of the main motivations for me
standing here is basically telling you
about that and not so much about the
specific library okay so let me just
repeat that question so the question was
whether we have looked into other tools
okay
so literal tools with the Z at the end
so in general we have looked at
different tools and at the point where
we developed your math so I should add I
wouldn't I wasn't there when Gemma was
being developed I only recently joined
the company so but yeah the the people
who originally developed definitely
looked at other tools and at that point
there was really nothing else there that
quite did what we wanted to do there in
particular one of the main motivations
what was this stuff about being able to
assign labels and to do the control flow
at the pipeline level there was
something we didn't really see anywhere
else
regarding your specific question tools
again I'm not really in experts there so
I'm not quite sure but I don't think
that in particular stuff like this
labeling you can easily do you perhaps
you could do it but it's not really made
for that so I guess that would be my
answer
what do you mean that it
you mean scaling out in terms of going
into a cluster direction I mean there
are two things to that so we have the
the okay I should again repeat the
question sorry so the question if I
understood it correctly was whether you
can automatically scale gamma true for
instance use a cluster solution so there
are two things to llamar so you have the
core library with these definitions of
splitters reduces and so on so and then
you have these back ends and I guess
your question regarding this scaling
that would be something that pertains
the back end
okay okay okay now I get the question so
the question is basically whether it's
possible to automatically for instance
determine how many chunks you have and
okay yeah um so this is something that's
not possible currently and I'm not quite
sure that we're going to go into that
direction because um in most use cases
we want the developer to have to control
to actually decide how many chunks there
are what is being split up there so if
we only have things like pandas
dataframes
for instance it would be possible to do
this possibly automatically but since
we're completely data agnostic we're
dealing with arbitrary Python objects
here it's really difficult to put that
logic into the library itself so that's
basically why we delegate that decision
to the developer
so again I should repeat the question so
the question was regarding this use of
tasks within a function and we haven't
really done it one of the people working
on the library played around a little
bit with this and the idea as far as I
understood it was basically you have
this graph that you get out of tasks and
perhaps it would be possible to use this
graph and just let it execute within
llamar for instance that would be the
basic idea sure yeah